you've heard your whole life that going
outside is good for you but is it really
I mean don't get me wrong there are some
definite healthy effects to going
outside like when you're exposed to
direct sunlight you get some vitamin D
and if you do exercise outside you're
getting exercise and I guess the air is
cleaner and more fresh so it's better
for you but what if you already get
exercise by going to the gym and what if
you take vitamin D supplements so you
don't need the vitamin D that you get
from direct sunlight and what if you
install a bunch of air purifiers in your
room to make the air clean and reduce it
of pollutants at that point would there
be any need to go outside anymore so I
did some extensive research on this
topic so that you don't have to and I
found out that going outside it still is
really really good for you and it has
some effects that nothing else can give
you and they're almost entirely
psychological benefits so here are five
incredible psychological benefits that
going outside gives you and before we
get started it's important to note that
research suggests that these benefits
are attained not by going for a walk
outside in a rural or urban environment
so taking a stroll downtown won't give
you these benefits they're more
specifically related to going outside in
natural environments so in order to
achieve any of these benefits you
actually have to go find some plants and
animals and stuff okay first benefit is
that your concentration will improve a
study published in 2008 found that
children with ADHD scored higher on a
test of concentration after a walk
through a park than after a walk through
a residential neighborhood or downtown
area well the study definitely was only
conducted on kids I'm sure it wouldn't
hurt to try it out yourself this study
at the very least emphasizes that
there's a huge difference between taking
a stroll downtown versus actually
spending time in real nature so if
you're not from a town that's completely
surrounded by nature already like I am
what I would suggest doing is opening
Google Maps and finding the nearest
green area and take a mental or digital
note of where that is you'll be far more
likely to spend some time in nature if
you actually know where to find it so
the second benefit of spending time in
nature is that you won't be as stressed
something about being outdoors changes
the physical expression of stress in the
body one study found that students sent
into the forest for two nights had lower
levels of cortisol a hormone often used
as a marker for stress then those who
spent that time
a city stressful states can be relieved
by forest therapy they concluded the
third benefit of spending time in nature
is that you won't be as tired you know
that feeling when the gears of your
brain feel like it's operating through
just sludge your entire perception of
reality is just shrouded in this type of
brain fog researchers call that mental
fatigue and one thing that can help kick
your brain back into gear is spending
time in restorative environments which
research has found generally means
outdoors one study found that people's
menergy menergy exclusive to men one
study found that people's mental energy
bounced back even after looking at a
picture of nature that compared that
with pictures of a city which had no
effect studies have also found that
exposure to natural beauty elicits
feelings of paw which is one of the
surest ways to improve your mental state
- the fourth benefit of spending time in
nature is that you won't be as depressed
or anxious researchers at the University
of Essex in England have found that
while exercising definitely does
increase overall self-esteem and mood
exercising in nature even for just five
minutes amplifies that effect so if
you're regularly working out and you're
still kind of gloomy bringing your
exercises outside into a green area
might make all the difference another
study found that walks in the forest
were associated with decreased levels of
anxiety and bad moods and yet another
study found that outdoor walks could be
useful clinically as a supplement to
existing treatments for major depressive
disorder and finally the fifth benefit
that you get from spending time outdoors
is that you may perform better on
creative tasks a study found that people
immersed in nature for 4 days which is
longer than your average walk in the
park boosted their performance on
creative problem-solving tests by a
whopping 50 percent speaking of which if
you're especially interested in this
specific benefit I have a whole video on
how to increase your creativity I'll put
the link in the description for that
video and you can check it out so that's
it there are a ton more psychological
benefits that you can get from going
outside
I only cover these five because they
seem to be the most consistently
unanimous across everywhere I research
but either way if you find that there's
something missing in your life perhaps
escaping your computer cave and smelling
the breeze is exactly what you need to
make you feel fulfilled rather help me
up
I'm down if you liked this video and
found it useful hit that like button and
if you like videos like these in general
hit that subscribe button also if you're
already subscribed there's a little bail
notification right under the video and
if you click it you can turn
notifications on so whenever I release a
new video you'll be notified be sure to
follow me on twitter at better ideas TV
also I've sort of revamped the Instagram
a little bit it's not great yet but if
you are on Instagram and feel like
following my account it's also at better
ideas TV that's all for today thank you
for watching and we'll catch you in the
next video